[Musique]
elle fait partie du patrimoine
audiovisuel français c'est Daniel
Lumbroso avec plus d'une cinquantaine
d'émissions à la télévision ou à la
radio Daniela Lumbroso nous accompagne
depuis plus de 40 ans maintenant
comptabilité au début des années 90
cette journaliste de formation commence
à voler de ses propres ailes en étant la
tête d'émission à gros budget comme jeu
sans frontières sur Antenne 2 à l'époque
bonsoir Daniela
culture l'animatrice est multiplié les
programmes musicaux tout au long de sa
carrière tube d'un jour tube de toujours
des spécial variétés sur Aznavour ou
Céline Dion sur TF1 Chabada sur france
télé et bien d'autres parce qu'ils sont
tous vraiment top mais entre 2005 et
2016 elle mettra l'honneur la musique
française dont elle est éperdument
amoureuse dans la fête de la chanson
française sur France 2 une émission qui
revisite extraordinaire patrimoine
musicale de notre pays merci
infiniment aujourd'hui à l'antenne sur
la station France Bleu chaque semaine
l'animatrice n'a pas fini de nous faire
vivre sa passion Daniela Lumbroso est
notre invité ce soir
[Applaudissements]
un peu autour pendant quelques semaines
pour le boulot
donc je précise quand même ce que je me
suis penché beaucoup sur votre carrière
50 émissions de variété des émissions
culte parmi lesquelles tubes d'un jour
tuent toujours la fête de la chanson
française Chabada 3 ans bien sûr la
chanson numéro 1 grande journée je le
disais LCI avant de devenir chef du
service culture vous avez reçu
Houellebecq j'entends mais sont vos
produits
c'est fou de voir il y a un petit côté
pardon mais c'est trop une c'est-à-dire
qu'ils aient le 20H à midi et qui
pouvait faire les vacettes le soir
c'est-à-dire c'était vraiment le le
grand
journaliste cultivé animatrice de
divertissement je n'ai qu'une question
que j'ai posé là en écrivant hier à
minuit pourquoi aujourd'hui la
télévision se passe de vous
d'abord la télévision se passe pas
vraiment de moi puisque je produis des
émissions et qu'il y en a une qui
passera mardi ce mardi
matin
il s'est trouvé qu'à un moment
on a souhaité renouveler les générations
et voilà
non alors c'est trop court parce que
déjà pourquoi alors on peut plus dire
que ta télévision
TF1 des femmes France de des femmes les
après-midi de France Télévisions des
femmes de l'interdit de des femmes pas
une question d'âge Sophie Davant
Boccolini donc c'est pas on peut même
pas dire tout ça et en plus on est un
peu ce que je disais sur le retour un
peu des gold on va revenir de Chavannes
on va revenir fontaine bataille on va
revenir la gaffe sur RMC donc les gold
reviennent et les gens les aiment
pourquoi pas vous je sais pas vous avez
une interprétation
je pense que déjà le pourquoi pas vous
pour moi c'est on ne fait revenir aucune
femme gold à l'antenne Christine Bravo
ne revient pas on fait réunir des hommes
mais il y a pas de femme est-ce que vous
pensez que la télévision
hormis la misogynie n'a pas envie de
voir des femmes d'un certain âge à
l'antenne je pense vraiment que c'est
pas le problème aujourd'hui les choses
ont beaucoup changé parce qu'il y a eu
MiTo il y a quelques années il y a une
dizaine d'années
moi j'ai arrêté à peu près de présenter
des missions en 2016 c'était un peu plus
problématique mais aujourd'hui c'est
plus le cas du tout je trouve que il y a
une vraiment ça fonctionne
très très gentil
c'est le nouveau Matthieu c'est le
retour de Clément guérinaire
mais vraiment c'est est-ce que des
chaînes vous ont contacté oui ou non et
si oui est-ce que c'est vous qui refusez
ce que vous propose vous êtes très
langue de bois le but début de
l'interview ça ça me fait pas du tout
derrière parce que là je vous ai fait
revenir j'ai des gros projets pour vous
parce que quand j'étais sur C8 Direct 8
à l'époque avec mon ordini vous étiez
venu une émission était grande comme ça
vous étiez adorable donc là je vais te
je vais être votre truc
vous allez décoller la le talent ça
s'arrête jamais
est-ce qu'une chaîne vous a contacté
est-ce que vous a proposé des choses qui
vous plaisent pas en fait tout
simplement ou est-ce que vous vous
contacte pas d'abord moi j'ai pas
particulièrement envie de revenir à
l'antenne pour
je vous assure que c'est vrai par
exemple il y a des émissions que j'ai
déjà présenté par le passé je n'aurais
pas envie de refaire si aujourd'hui je
faisais une émission ce serait par
rapport à un contenu un peu différent ou
voilà des choses qui m'intéressent
davantage dans la période dans laquelle
je suis aujourd'hui
par exemple
je parle des interviews
voilà des différentes choses
quoi
des talks politiques
un peu comme Léa Salamé ce qu'elle fait
sur France est-ce que vous accepteriez
de
déjà c'est compliqué parfois mais par
une porte plus simple comme de savane
comme comme chroniqueur pour revenir un
peu enfin si le projet est intéressant
pourquoi pas mais là aujourd'hui je fais
de la télévision je produis des
émissions j'aime beaucoup ce que je fais
je fais toujours des beaux programmes
qui me font très plaisir donc
vous m'agacez
il y a Mathieu méchant Mathieu lunette
attention
il y a eu Jacques hippique gentil
Jacquie méchant non mais au téléphone on
s'est dit des choses quand même on s'est
dit aussi est-ce que c'est pas une
histoire de réseau est-ce que vous avez
rencontré des final
je travaille à France Télévisions
mais je parle pas d'antenne parce que
c'est pas un souhait c'est pas quelque
chose si j'étais allé proposer quelque
chose en disant je veux absolument être
à l'antenne et qu'on m'avait dit non
mais là en l'occurrence il y a pas eu de
discussions très bien donc on vous
propose une
maintenant elle a envie d'avoir ce
qu'elle aime elle veut faire ce qu'elle
aime alors ma question pourquoi est-ce
que vous aimez on vous le propose pas
parce que ça n'existe pas
[Rires]
c'est très judicieux ce qu'il dit c'est
vrai j'ai une petite explication non
j'ai une petite j'ai une petite
explication si vous me la permettez
parce que dans le bureau j'ai pas les
gens ont plus envie de me voir aussi
est-ce que vous voulez voir Daniela
[Applaudissements]
non mais
non mais c'est voilà c'est c'est juste
étonnant que voilà c'est pas très clair
vous voulez faire un taux mais on sait
pas très bien sur quoi faire quoi un toc
de quoi qui parle de quoi de politique
c'est pas clair
elle a dit
la connaissez un peu c'est du réseau
vous savez il y a même des gens on dit
que parfois les anciens animateurs quand
il ne reviennent pas à l'antenne pendant
très longtemps je dis pas ça pour vous
c'est qu'ils se sont pas toujours
peut-être bien comporter avec j'adore
Christophe Dechavanne mais ça traversait
du désert il a peut-être pas été aimable
il avait beaucoup de gens pendant
longtemps il a un petit peu payé ça il
est manque de main tendus vous je pense
que vous avez été adorable pourquoi
aujourd'hui il y a pas ses mains tendues
est-ce que c'est 8 vous a fait une
proposition non menteuse
on vous a pas fait une proposition à
quelques années
[Rires]
quelle proposition non je vois pas TPMP
le grand
de C8 vous a appelé pour vous dire on a
peut-être un petit projet oui le Grand 8
production peut-être mais
c'est plutôt flatteur je serais très
heureuse mais non d'accord si vous avez
une chaîne à choisir comme ça ce serait
laquelle il y a une chaîne que vous
aimez particulièrement non je trouve que
non
en fait Daniela vous n'avez pas envie de
télé vous n'avez rien ne vous intéresse
vous émettez j'ai envie d'exprimer
éventuellement quelque chose mais je
n'ai pas particulièrement envie de télé
je trouve que la télé aujourd'hui en
plus d'être exposée tout le temps plus
les réseaux sociaux c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même assez violent et
assez difficile et que je suis très très
heureuse dans ce que j'ai deux
explications est-ce que vous me les
permettez la première c'est que dans le
bureau l'autre jour je disais d'aller en
brosseaux tout le monde connaît son nom
c'est un concept vous avez animé environ
50 émissions mais c'est vrai que parfois
les gens disent 50 émissions mais je
peux si tu es vraiment une alors moi
quand j'ai revu votre truc j'ai vu votre
votre bio j'ai vu Chabada mais c'est
vrai que sur le moment vous avez
tellement fait d'unitaire que on sait
plus trop où vous placez est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a pas un peu de ça aussi
on sait pas trop Laurence il y a que les
vérité qui compte il faut le dire
toujours qu'on est l'émission d'une on
est l'homme d'une émission est-ce que
vous êtes la femme d'une émission c'est
parfait c'est très juste c'est parce que
j'ai fait beaucoup d'émissions avec des
marques différentes et voilà sur pas mal
d'années finalement il y a eu Chabada
quand même pendant 4 ans je pense que
c'est un petit peu marqué une partie des
téléspectateurs et puis il y a eu LCI où
je faisais une émission culturelle
pendant 7 ans mais c'est vrai que c'est
tout ça est très différent mais c'est
parce que j'aime encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs j'ai envie d'aller vers des
choses différentes et vous êtes vous en
parler donc vous êtes en couple avec
Eric
Jebali pardon
voilà qui avait rejoint le Parti
socialiste dans les 80 est-ce que Audrey
Pulvar l'avait dit ça aussi non mais
pardon
pas réveiller aussi c'est très compliqué
d'être marié avec quelqu'un qui a une
étiquette politique est-ce que ça aussi
vous pensez que ça peut jouer
aujourd'hui non je pense pas du tout pas
du tout non vraiment vous avez surtout
pas
du tout et deux questions après je vous
laisse aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
regardez la télé alors je regarde
beaucoup de séries sur Netflix et
qu'est-ce que vous n'aimez pas la télé
aujourd'hui vraiment qu'est-ce que
j'aime pas je regarde pas beaucoup de
téléréalité mais bon parce que c'est
sans doute pas ma génération d'accord
qu'est-ce que j'aime pas la télé non il
y a de bonnes émissions je trouve qu'il
y en a quand même une télé avec beaucoup
de choses intéressantes à regarder
d'accord alors j'ai donné le passé
quelques jeunes moi j'ai découvert et ça
je ne le savais pas que vous aviez sorti
un disque à l'époque
j'ai regardé et j'ai regardé sur Youtube
le clip etc et j'ai un petit plaisent
j'adore
[Musique]
avec les garçons
tout la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la jeune fille qui est en bleu c'est
Elsa zilbersteinte
est-ce que vous une question à Laurent
qui qui connaît bien quelques nuits
aussi une traversée du désert qui
revient aujourd'hui toi c'est quoi ton
ton analyse de producteur et d'animateur
sur sur Daniela George de producteur sur
des élèves on la conduite
très très longtemps on n'est pas amis
dans la ville on est bon copain et on a
produit dans dans le plus grand plaisir
des trucs je sens qu'elle a été victime
du système France Télévisions Daniela je
veux pas dire ça devant elle mais elle a
beaucoup beaucoup vécu à France
Télévisions et pour connaître un peu
cette ce groupe de chaîne de télé c'est
pas simple ça a de nombreuses qualités
ça a beaucoup de défauts et je pense que
voilà à force de rester dans ce groupe
là et et et et d'y faire ce qu'elle y a
fait ben elle a payé des certaines
choses ouais je pense
qu'une animatrice et quand elle fait un
peu sa mine aux deux en mode la télé
j'ai pas renforcé mais envie de revenir
c'est vrai parce que c'est une
productrice Daniel avant moi j'ai bossé
avec elle j'ai pas eu une animatrice en
face de moi j'ai eu une collègue
productrice donc voilà qui s'y connaît
c'est parfaitement son métier et je
pense que voilà France Télé vous savez
très bien qu'il y a ceux qui restent
pendant 50 ans on va en citer
quelques-uns certains marchent certains
ont pas forcément des audiences fait
sont toujours là et tous les années
toutes les années ils ont leur case
Daniela elle a peut-être été un peu plus
friable à un moment donné ça le faisait
moins il y avait pas les mêmes raisons
pas les mêmes dirigeants en france télé
et ben c'est au revoir voilà c'est aussi
simple que ça vous choque que toutes les
filles un peu âgées disparaissent de la
télévision
non mais pas vous mais les filles un peu
âgées et que Nelson Monfort elle
demandait une dérogation en 70 ans il a
eu encore une fois moi je trouve que la
situation a changé c'était très vrai il
y a une dizaine d'années où vraiment il
y avait énormément d'hommes de plus de
50 ans et pas une seule femme
aujourd'hui vraiment on peut pas dire
qui est une différence entre de
traitement entre les hommes et les
femmes heureuse
Joseph Agostini vous écrivez aussi vous
êtes
productrice et vous écrivez aussi les
chansons d'amour guérissent le cœur du
monde c'est beau ça en tout cas
en plus donc voilà écrit à quatre mains
ce que je vais vous écrivez vous
produisez vous on y va ah je m'ennuie
pas du tout ce livre
explique en son amour qui n'a pas pleuré
c'est la femme de Chabada qui est sorti
d'amour c'est cohérent et puis là il y a
une émission d'amour pour la
Saint-Valentin donc à Paris
[Rires]
retiré de tout ça genre un peu je lui en
Provin
je suis très content de savoir que vous
allez très très bien merci beaucoup
Daniela d'avoir été avec nous